what's up guys we're on our way to watch
more videos on the screening about 90
minutes away they're gonna reveal right
afterwards so we're gonna need to keep
our energy up energy we're gonna need to
focus on focus because between driving
screening filming and editing it's gonna
be like nine hours in total endurance
and we're gonna wanna make sure to give
you the sharpest reaction right after
screening it we react that's what we do
because we want to thank our video
sponsor today g fuel we're gonna stop
with this next ring infused plasma
flavor
we're up all hours of the day and night
ain't no rest ain't no breath we're very
biased
g-fuel is gluten and sugar-free vitamin
and antioxidant fortified to keep us
alert and focused for these late night
filming and editing runs 40 flavors for
taste bud variety so hit up that link in
the description box and we'll see you
after the movie we vape
[Music]
well
we just got out of morbius had a special
screening that apparently coy was
hosting
they found me
you're going to be in the video with us
now yeah here i am all right guys look
it's no secret if you watch the real
rejects john and i have heard some
things about this movie some some awful
things and
i'm not gonna lie
i'm really not just saying this
i was like
it's not that bad
talk about shocks this is not a train
wreck i think people are expecting a
different thing and this is the thing i
wanted so i was happy look look i'm not
gonna [ __ ] you guys like i think
that there were times where i was like
kind of checking out a little bit the
kind of image that this movie was
getting beforehand is like oh this is a
disaster i'm like no for the most part
yeah it's a little silly it's a little
cheesy sometimes it takes itself a
little too serious where it falls flat
instead of feeling dramatically weighty
when the movie thinks it is is it rushed
and choppy at times yeah i mean i didn't
think it was like rushed to the degree i
felt venom let there be carnage was
however there are plenty of scenes where
it was very obvious stuff was cut out so
obvious a more breathable less non-stop
info dumb back-to-back scenes version of
this exists could have been rated r to
make the action better a thousand
percent could the movie have overall
been more interesting and better yeah
would it have been getting as much crap
if it was just on streaming probably not
but i don't know i i think a lot of this
has to do with my expectations were solo
and seeing how sony handled venom i was
like yeah this lines up and yet for the
most part i was still consistently
amused i thought the actors showed up
and some of the action and effects were
all right so yeah it's fine
i don't think it's as horrible as people
have been making it out to be matt smith
though matt smith man smith absolutely
yeah
matt smith
mvp of the movie definitely he was my
favorite part the trailers remarkably
didn't show a whole lot of them there's
a lot of the movie that is not in the
trailers and a lot of that is matt smith
and he's in it much more prominent than
uh the trailers let on at all and he has
the most arc he is the most interesting
character and he's having the most fun
and he elevates the movie the most i
can't stress that enough matt smith is
like the best part of the film it did
feel like a night i thought you were
when you said i was serious i thought
you were just like being kind no it's a
very intentional tone
it is good it's a it's like a 90s
vampire movie and i love that because
that's what i wanted it to be yeah it's
kind of like a 90s vampire movie but a
little bit void of the violence so john
and i cracked up at one point in this
movie when someone's throat gets slashed
and uh it's just like they have all the
sound effects
yeah he had given blood that day
actually so there wasn't much left to go
around very easy to catch i mean i
actually really liked martine as well i
thought she was a great presence aside
from just like the geekiness of like oh
i love matt smith and he's doing a great
job here i thought that she was actually
perhaps the most standout character
aside from him like i thought she
brought a good amount of heart and
played off jared leto well i also love
that every supporting cast member had
fun like with their like jared harris is
a great time and tyrese is a great time
and al madrigal getting to just play
much like a 90s vampire movie everyone's
just vibing and having a good time
knowing what movie it is i think coy's
level of enthusiasm for this movie koi's
having a blast
and john are like
yeah it was fun it's all right
had a good time it was a good time it's
terrible i don't necessarily agree that
everyone was in the same movie but i
enjoyed watching everyone
oh nikoi i gotta disagree with you okay
who was not
i'm gonna do an impression of you for
every tyrese gibson scene all right a
scene's happening
i'm out of magical i'm making jokes
tyrese walks in
i say one line
and you see
but incredibly serious line at that
is that not a 90s vampire movie he's the
same movie everyone else is in he's not
he's not a character
he's just you could excise that plot
line completely from the movie and it
would not change but you know what you
wouldn't have tyreese
i'd be sorry isn't even charismatic in
this movie
two things i liked tyra's not bad for
now so uh i'm glad they kept that plot
the tyrese gibson and then who's the guy
who played his partner al madrigal
yeah daily show correspondent genius
writer comic book they did not have
chemistry his jokes all landed flat i
don't recall one time people left no
there was one joke actually there was
one joke for sure for sure out of like
50.
at a certain point in time my brain just
kind of normalized it is no this is just
how this character speaks and there's no
real humorous or non-humorous value to
that this is how this guy speaks it was
a little bit more violent than i was
expecting at times there were times
where i was like oh
you're not quite r-rated but you're
you're you're
doing something i also think it got it
captured this really cool like tense
claustrophobic tone that i liked keeping
unique to this like it has that very 90s
everything feels very rotten taught and
i really think that's something we are
not getting in the superhero genre as
much yes i thought
i didn't ever find it intense look i
don't hate this movie i'm really not
just saying that for me i'm like no it's
it's perfectly enjoyable like that's
that's the thing is it's in it it's so
like not
offensive and then just like do you like
vampire movies you'll probably like this
one yeah i would happily watch a morbius
2. but yeah i think like geraldo is
actually not bad in the movie i don't
think he's like special per se my
concern was that jared leto would be
boring in this movie i really thought he
might be boring this feels like the most
like you're just hanging out with actual
jared leto in a weird way it felt like
we're just hanging out with a guy that
was enjoyable to me it's meant as a
compliment it is like i've been doing
press for this full disclosure i'm at
the event that i was hosting i recently
hung out jared leto it is and like it's
interesting you know what i mean and
like i like the vibe they captured of
morbius because michael morbius has the
dichotomy the hippocratic oath and also
the thirst and you feel that tension i
think yeah they taught they do the
outline man uh they do execute a plot i
think freaking matt smith scenes are all
great some of the action scenes well
while the cgi is kind of back and forth
because i feel like there were times
where the cgi looked like really good
where i thought they were doing
practical effects but then when you see
the way they handle some shots you're
like oh there's no way that could be
practical effects that has to be a cgi
shot sometimes it looks like a cut scene
in a this is like a
zombie arcade game is how i put it like
a modern day zombie arcade game or some
of the fight scenes but sometimes i'm
like it's pretty cool some of you guys
have heard about the post-credits scenes
what how on the internet when the movie
just ended i was like
oh it's just it's just over like i
thought there was going to be like 10 to
15 more minutes to wrap this movie up i
thought there was an act missing but it
just like
oh it's done and then they do the post
credit scenes and we had heard some of
the stuff about the post credit scenes
i'm not gonna lie to you guys
i thought they were a little worse than
what i even heard
i was kind of surprised the movie is so
much better than the post-credits scenes
and the post-credits scenes just raised
so many questions for me where i was
like wait a minute what that was just me
like the entire time with the post
credits and it's like what what they are
shameless
i think there are solutions i just want
to see them i'll happily watch how those
post-credit scenes conclude and what
they blossom into later but as you know
marketing tools as most post-credit
scenes tend to be nowadays they really
felt like very transparent bullet point
marketing tools i felt like there was a
whole movie that happened off screen
between post credit scene 1 and postgres
scene 2. this is just one aspect of it
one aspect of it sort of felt like they
definitely cut out some scenes from the
actual movie and then re-shot some
scenes too to make the postcards scene
happen
and i wonder how much of that had to do
with like the order it come out in
because like this was supposed to come
out before no way home yeah yeah in
defense of morbius i keep describing
this is the third movie in the sony
universe of marvel characters i keep
describing them as universal monster
movies and i don't mean like universal
studios today i mean classic 40s and 50s
30s 40s and 50s universal monster movies
but with today's technology and those
movies are a blast and they're
interesting and what is beautiful about
the sony universe of marvel characters
is this keeps the pace different if
everything feels like one studio makes
it then we'll lose the bubble will burst
there's a reason dc diversifying its
content is succeeding there's a reason
we need movies to feel different this
and venom feel like a different thing
than the other movies made from this
comic book company and i think that's
its strength they might not be for
everyone but they are for a lot of
people i think this is as long as the
press doesn't keep people at home i
think this has the potential to do
really really well and i really want it
to because i want more of this so we
don't have the bubble burst we don't
have the same thing you want
more orbeez
either one pick your favorite out in the
comments who did the joke better
but i also know that and like it was the
joker last week at moonlight they were
like koi likes everything i just don't
talk about things i don't like there's
plenty that if you look in my letterbox
i don't enjoy i'm just like hiding from
it i prefer to hype things i liked this
at my age i liked it but if i was
between like 15 and 25 and hadn't grown
up with lost boys or interviewed the
vampire or the movies that shaped my
childhood i feel like matt smith
captured that oh dude me and matt talked
about that wow yeah i see the michael
thing i really feel like this should
have been
a matt smith's movie and he becomes like
at times he's the only part when i say
tense he's the only top part of the
movie that at times i felt some tension
sure otherwise i was just amused i was
consistently amused twice a little
sleepy like most part consistently
amused i know it sounds like a weird
discussion i was gonna say you know fun
enough you know you got sleepy twice
that's a solid three out of five it was
all right better than i expected i would
watch a second movie with better
versions of everything we saw here i
love the poster quote i kind of liked it
only sleeping twice correct albert real
paychecks like that it's the feeling i
had it's a fun vampire movie
i guess i feel like the vampire movie
comes from matt smith i think everything
else is kind of like it's more of a
science movie science experiment movie i
grew up in vampire movies i got a lot of
the love of vampire movies on screen i
also liked the cast a lot and i love
their dynamic all of them personally but
again like i grew up with this character
from the time i could read i really
loved morbius and i never thought we'd
see him so i cannot shake that i cannot
remove my bias of loving this character
and i also can't remove my bias of an
academy award-winning actor actually
caring enough to invest in this
character so there's no version of me
that can't be like man i got to be a kid
and i wanted that i got it and it's a
vampire movie that we don't get the
style of a lot had a good time
personally
yeah man no one's trying to take you
down they're not that's not the way i
feel like you're defending i'm defending
myself for the comments that are coming
you know what those comments are going
to say coy likes everything why do you
have them on the real rejects he's just
going to say it's good and they don't
know what i think about a lot of things
first thoughts toy's very enthusiastic
and john and i are like
sure
it's good enough try it out for me i
think it's
venom morbius then let there be carnage
that's how i would rank it i agree more
obvious is the top three and then you
know venom and venom two is all three
out of five
three out of five
did you like it more than the venom
movies no i liked them in the same order
you did
we're all venomous yeah yeah all right
guys well koi thanks for hopping in here
i'll go back to work gotta get my stuff
and g fuel your energy drink kept us
awake for this review
maybe if we didn't have g fuel we would
have been more bored so this movie kept
us away